اذا مشاهدينا كان هذا تقرير زميل صهيب
الخلف هذه العمليات التي تتابعونها الان
على الشاشه استمرار عمليات نبش الالقاب
ومحاوله اخراج من ما قيل على قيد الحياه
نحاول ان نفهم طبيعتها وكيف تتم ومل معدات
اللازمه وما الوقت اللازم للوصول الى من
كان حيا نحاول ان نستوضح هذه الامور مع
خبير في هذا الشان ينضم الينا الان من
كهرمان مرعش سبستيان هدى وهو احد عناصر
فريق الانقاذ الالماني الذي توجه
للمساعده في عمليات الانقاذ اهلا بك معنا
السيد نحاول ان نفهم معك مبدئيا ما الذي
تقومون به عند الوصول الى المبنى الذي
تحاولون اخراج العالقين من تحت انقاض
نحن فريق منظمه
ومهمتنا البحث عن الضحايا الاحياء تحت
الانقاض وامن ننقذهم من هذه الانقاض ومن
هذا الركن
اريد ان افهم معك طبيعه عملكم الان في ظل
هذه الظروف الصعبه الجويه بالدرجه الاولى
كيف تستطيعون الوصول الى هؤلاء هل هناك من
بروتوكول معين تقومون من خلال لو تشرح لنا
طريقه عملكم
بالطبع
الحراره
في منتهى البروده هنا وهذه الاوقات عصيبه
بالنسبه لنا اذا بعد ان
نحصل على معرفه بان هناك اشخاصا موجودين
نحاول ان نتخلص من الانقاض والركام لكي
ننتشل هؤلاء الاشخاص من تحت هذا الركام
بالنظر الى الى صعوبه الموقف الان في
كهرمان مرعش والعدد الكبير من المباني كيف
تحددون اولويه البحث كيف تقررون انهاء
العمل في مكان والانتقال الى اخر
نحن كلنا متطوعون ومنظمه غير حكوميه اذا
فنحن
نساعد في الظروف الصعبه التي
نشهدها في اماكن كثيره في العالم ولذلك
يعتبر هذا العمل هو من اولى اولوياتنا
فنحن ناخذ وقتا مقتطعا من وظائفنا الرسميه
لكي نقوم بمثل هذه الاعمال التطوعيه
[موسيقى]
اذا اردت ان افهم منك
مقارنه ليست المره الاولى التي تشارك فيها
في عمليه انقاذ ما المختلف فيما تشاهده
الان في كهرمان
هناك وجوه شبه وهو ان الناس المدنيين
يتضررون في الماضي عملنا فيها وفي نيبال
وهنا لدينا مباني كثيره انهارت وهناك
الكثيرون من الناس الذين هم تحت الانقاض
حتى
في ركامي مبنى واحد وهذا امر يعتبره امرا
لم نشده من قبل وهذا ما نعمله على
المساهمه في حل هذه المشكله هنا
هل المعدات كافيه بالنسبه لكم هناك دعوات
من تركيا
وطلب المزيد من المساعدات وهناك مساعدات
بالفعل لكنها تاتي باعداد محدوده حتى الان
وان كانت
متواتره حجم الكارثه كبير في كهرمان مرعش
كما ذكر الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان هل
المعدات كافيه
استيعاب كل هذه المباني المدمره بالنسبه
لكم هل تعتقد بانها كافيه من خلال تجربتك
الى الان نحن ناتي بكل شيء نحتاجه لذلك
لدينا كل ما يلزمنا وايضا نحن ناتي
بالمواد مثل المواد التي هي تساعدنا في
البحث والانقاذ وايضا ناتي بالمياه
والطعام اللازم للقيام بمهامنا في مثل هذه
الظروف الصعبه
لاحظنا نحن اثناء متابعه وهنا هذا مكان
اخر تتم فيها عمليه الانقاذ وبالليل ايضا
بالامس ان هناك طلب متكرر بلزوم الصمت ما
الجهاز الذي يتم استخدامه بحيث يطلب من كل
من هم في المحيط اغلاق الجوالات والصمت
المطبق كيف تصلون الى تاكيد بان هناك شخص
تحت الانقاض كيف تفهمون ذلك
نحن
نستخدم
اجهزه هاتفيه خاصه تلتقط الصوت من
بين الركام
وهذه هي طريقه تحديد
مواقع الناس
وايضا نحن استطعنا ان نتواصل مع هؤلاء
الناس عن طريق استخدام هذه الهواتف الخاصه
هنا سؤال ربما يكون حساس فيما يتعلق
باتخاذ قرار هل هناك احياء ام لا ماذا لو
كان الشخص مغما عليه ليس في وعيه لكنه على
قيد الحياه هل يمكن فهم ذلك باي طريقه
والوصول اليه
[موسيقى]
هذا يعتبر قرارا صعبا جدا
وفي الواقع نحن نحاول ان نضع الاولويات
بشان الضحايا الذين لديهم فرصه عاليه
بالنجاح اذا فنحن نبحث في الاماكن التي
يمكن ان يكون فيها اماكن يمكن ان يكون
فيها الناس لكي نقوم بالعمل على انقاذهم
وانتشالهم احياء
هل نجحتم حتى الان بطبيعه الحال سمعنا عن
عدد كبير من الناس يخرج وحيا وتم انقاذهم
بالنسبه لتجربتك الشخصيه الان في هذا
المجال هل يمكن ان تحدثنا عن ذلك من خرجوا
من تحت ايديكم احياء من تحت هذه الانقاذ
هذا هو الهدف الذي
نسعى من اجل تحقيقه
ونتلقى الكثير من التدريب من اجل القيام
بهذه المهمه الصعبه
وبالطبع ما نقوم به الان هو الامر الصائب
ونحن نكون مسرورين عندما ننقذ اي شخص
بالنسبه للموعد المحدد
لانهاء عمليه الانقاذ هل هو
دقيق هل يمكن ان نقول بانه بعد ثلاثه ايام
اربعه ايام خمسه ايام تقل فرص الوصول
لناجين ما هو الرقم الاعلى اليوم الابعد
الذي يمكن ان ننتظره في هذا الاطار
يجعب ان نجم بهذا الان
بمرور الوقت
الحصول على الناجين تتضاءل ولكن يعتمد
الامر على المهندسين وفرق البحث والانقاذ
وايضا الاطر البيئيه والجويه مثل درجه
الحراره ولكن في ظل كل هذه الظروف نحن
نحاول ان نفعل اقصى ما بوسعنا لانقاذ
هؤلاء الناس
سبستيان هدى وواحد عناصر فريق الانقاذ
الالماني من كهرمان مرعش شكرا جزيلا لك
على كل هذه الاضاحات ربما قربتنا اكثر